Whoa. This is legit high.
- I'm scared.
- Me too.
But I'm done letting fear
stop me from living.
She just finished chemo
a couple weeks ago.
I'm not sure Ella is ready
for school tomorrow.
Carl, we've discussed this.
And the Santa Ana
winds are blowing.
I didn't catch cancer
from the wind,
so I'm guessing it's not
going to bring it back.
Ella. Come on.
I finally get to be
a regular teenage girl.
Staying up all night.
Eating candy.
Drinking soda.
Pretend I didn't hear
any of that.
All your adventurousness has
really rubbed off on me.
Eww.
That is a side effect
of my friendship.
Today I'm alive.
And I don't plan on shying
away from anything.
Forget yesterday.
I want to make some
new memories.
Don't hit me with any
of that meditation junk.
Hey! That junk works.